We know that the sum of angles within a triangle is 180 degrees.
Let's prove that for triangle ABC.
To prove that we need to do a small bit of construction.
We draw a line 'EF' passing through point 'A' and parallel to 'BC'.
It will look like this.
It passes through point 'A' and is parallel to 'BC'.
You can see, that many angles are formed. Let's name them.
Let this be angle one,
let this be angle two,
and let this be angle three.
Angles one, two and three are the interior angles.
of the triangle, and their sum equals '180' degrees.
There are two more angles that are formed outside the triangle.
Let's call them angle four and angle five.
Before we move forward let us understand a new concept.
Assume these are two parallel lines,
and there is a transversal that cuts those lines.
Let this be angle four and this be angle two.
In such a case, angle two will always equal angle 4.
These are alternate interior angles.
Remember, the transversal has to cut two parallel lines.
Now let's zoom out and look at the original figure.
'BC' and 'EF' are parallel lines.
And angle 2 and angle 4 are alternate interior angles.
Which is why angle 2, will equal angle 4.
If you look at the figure carefully,
you will notice that angle 3 and angle 5 are alternate interior angles too.
'AC' is the transversal which intersects these two parallel lines.
It means that angle 3 will also be equal to angle 5.
Both these pairs are alternate interior angles.
What we are interested in is the sum of these three angles.
Angle 1 plus angle 2 plus angle 3.
Since angle 2 is equal to angle 4, and angle 3 is equal to angle 5,
we can write this as angle one, plus angle four plus angle five.
We just replaced angles two and three with angles four and five.
What does this tell you?
Look at the figure and see where angles one, four and five are placed?
'EF' is a straight line and since 'EF' is a straight line,
we know that the sum of angle 1, angle 4 and angle 5
will equal 180 degrees.
It implies that the sum of angles one, two and three,
will also equal 180 degrees.